Una pregunta ¿Conocéis a Peter Thiel?
Probablemente sí.
Fue uno de los fundadores de Paypal, el primer
inversor en Facebook y es uno de los gurús
de tecnología y capital riesgo más importantes
del mundo.
Por supuesto es multimillonario y sobre todo,
un tipo... curioso.
Entre sus hazañas está financiar, por ejemplo,
proyectos para construir ciudades en alta
mar o investigaciones para luchar contra la
muerte.
(Pero Peter Thiel también es conocido por ser
el mayor apoyo de Donald Trump en Silicon Valley...)
Sí, es verdad, pero en conversaciones con
periodistas ya ha mostrado... dudas.
Además, qué diantres, todo el mundo, nosotros
los primeros, tenemos derecho a equivocarnos.
¿No os parece?
El caso es que en 2011 Peter Thiel consiguió
la nacionalidad neozelandesa, se convirtió
en todo un kiwi, y dijo esto:
(“Estoy feliz de poder decir que no he encontrado
otro país que coincida más con mi forma
de ver el futuro que Nueva Zelanda".
La verdad, lo sabéis, en VisualPolitik, esto
es algo que no nos sorprende.
Ya os hemos contado en dos vídeos anteriores
que Nueva Zelanda es un país que nos encanta.
No solo porque es uno de los países más
bonitos del mundo…
También porque es todo un ejemplo a seguir.
Fijaos en estas declaraciones, en bromas,
del Primer Ministro, Bill English, sobre el
anterior Primer Ministro:
(“En ocasiones John Key se quejaba de que
era el único líder que no tenía un avión
del gobierno y de cómo sus colegas estaban
horrorizados al enterarse de que tenía que
viajar en aviones comerciales.
Pero yo le aseguraba que eso reforzaba su
carácter y le mantenía en contacto con la
gente normal”.
Sí, Nueva Zelanda no tiene avión oficial…
A cambio es el país del mundo donde más
fácil resulta hacer negocios, es - como ya vimos -
el país más próspero, uno de los menos
corruptos y uno de los más seguros de todo
el planeta.
Y ojo, porque los servicios públicos son de bandera.
Como ejemplo, os voy a contar una experiencia
personal.
¿Veis esta tarjeta?
Pues es mi tarjeta del servicio de bibliotecas
de Auckland.
En este país, amigos, las bibliotecas son
algo impresionante: cómodas, con wifi de
alta velocidad gratis, con bancos de música
y un montón de servicios.
De verdad, están muy, muy bien montadas.
Es algo que merece conocer porque sorprende.
Y tan solo en Auckland hay 55 bibliotecas
públicas.
Pero no solo eso, como sabéis es uno de los
países con más nivel de vida y más empleo.
Fijaos, por ejemplo en este gráfico:
Vamos, que el país merece la pena.
Ahora bien, no penseis que siempre fue así.
NO SIEMPRE SALIÓ EL SOL
Nueva Zelanda es un país top.
Pero, amigos, las cosas a los kiwis... no
les fueron siempre tan bien, para nada.
Lo que vamos a ver a continuación es una
historia real, la historia de un país que
tuvo la determinación de aprender de sus
errores, de transformar todo aquello que no
funcionaba y convertirse, así, en todo un
modelo.
Y, ojo, porque no hablamos de algo que sea,
precisamente ni fácil ni habitual.
Poner a las personas por delante de ideologías
e intereses electorales no es nada común.
Al menos... en los países de habla hispana.
Pero seguro que te estas preguntando… ¿pero qué
es lo que pasó?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
Hay que decir que Nueva Zelanda siempre fue
un país relativamente rico.
De hecho, a finales de la década de los 50
este país tenía el tercer ingreso per cápita
más alto de todo mundo… no está mal, ¿verdad?
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, porque a
partir de ese instante las cosas empezaron
a torcerse… hasta tal punto que en 1984,
atentos, el ingreso per cápita de Nueva Zelanda
estaba a la altura del de Portugal o Turquía,
tal como lo escucháis.
Y, claro, puede que ahora te estés preguntando
ahora mismo ¿qué diantres hicieron en este
país para que esto pasara?
Pues podemos decir que al gobierno se le fue
un poquito la mano.
Por aquella época el gobierno de Nueva Zelanda
tenía intervenida la economía hasta un extremo
que hoy cuesta imaginarse:
Había muchísimos impuestos, eran complejos
y muy altos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el tipo más
alto del impuesto de la renta llegaba casi
al 70% y por abajo casi al 40%, que se dice
pronto.
Y desde luego las empresas no salían mejor
paradas.
El impuesto sobre beneficios era del 48%,
el doble de lo que es habitual hoy en el mundo.
Además, había montones de regulaciones,
pero…. montones:
controles de precios para casi todos los productos,
controles de divisas… por ejemplo, cualquier
importación requería la aprobación expresa
de la administración y los neozelandeses
tienen muy, pero que muy complicado, invertir su dinero
fuera del país.
(“Teníamos controles de divisas que significaban
que no podía comprar una suscripción a The
Economist sin el permiso del Ministerio de
Hacienda”.)
Fijaos hasta donde llegaban los controles
y las regulaciones que no solo estaban fijados
los salarios mínimos… también los máximos.
Si, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Por ejemplo, si un empresario en un momento
dado le quería pagar un bonus a sus trabajadores…
bueno… digamos que era una tarea, como decirlo...
complicada… Sí, ¡de locos!
Y, por supuesto, como ya os podéis imaginar,
el estado era dueño y señor de prácticamente
todas las grandes empresas nacionales:
telecomunicaciones, aerolíneas, compañías de seguros, bancos, hoteles...
¿Qué diantres hacía el gobierno gestionando
hoteles?
Vamos, en otras palabras, la Nueva Zelanda
de principios de los años 80 era todo un
ejemplo de estatismo llevado casi al extremo.
De una forma u otra, prácticamente todo era
controlado por los políticos y burócratas.
¿Las consecuencias?
Pues no precisamente muy positivas...
Tras 23 años de déficit en las cuentas del
gobierno, la deuda pública se había disparado,
el desempleo superaba los dos dígitos, la
inversión privada huía despavorida del país
y los jóvenes kiwis, que es como se llama
a la gente de este país, se marchaban en masa.
Claro, por aquel entonces hacer negocios en
Nueva Zelanda era algo complicado, algo solo
para valientes… y claro, así…. pues no
se puede.
Ahora bien, en 1984 hubo elecciones y… todo
empezó a cambiar.
UN PLAN PARA SALIR ADELANTE
En 1984, bajo un contexto de crisis muy dura
se celebraron elecciones, las ganó el
Partido Laborista de David Lange , el partido de centro izquierda.
El nuevo gobierno llegó con una misión:
superar la crisis y cambiar el modelo de país.
Sustituir todo lo que no funcionaba y asegurarse,
eso sí, de que nadie se quedase atrás…
pero al mismo tiempo que a nadie se le impidiera
avanzar.
Pues bien, aunque David Lange fue el Primer
Ministro, el líder de todo el proceso fue,
el Ministro de Finanzas, Sir Roger Douglas
con lo que se vino a conocer el “rogernomics”.
Aquí, en VisualPolitik, ya mencionamos este
plan en un pasado vídeo, cuando hablamos
de las reformas agrícolas que tanto éxito
han tenido en este país.
Pero el “rogernomics”, amigos, no se quedó
solo en la agricultura, para nada.
El plan afectó a prácticamente todos los
resquicios del estado y puso en pie una nueva
cultura política.
De hecho, cuando unos años más tarde, en
1990, el Partido Nacional, el partido de centro-derecha
neozelandés ganó las elecciones y volvió
al poder, ya todo había cambiado y el nuevo
gobierno continuó la estela del plan laborista.
Una filosofía política que entre 1984 y
principios del s.XXI cambió radicalmente
el país.
Todo esto que vamos a ver, amigos, no es VisualPolitik,
es... la historia.
Dicho esto, lo primero que hizo el nuevo gobierno
fue declarar la guerra a la burocracia.
Y lo hicieron de tres formas:
-> Primero, hicieron un examen minucioso a
cada departamento del gobierno.
Si lo que hacían no era imprescindible o
lo hacía mejor el mercado... pues punto y
final.
Bajo esta misma filosofía, por ejemplo, se
puso en marcha un ambicioso plan de privatizaciones,
pero de las de verdad, no de las regalar empresas
públicas a los amiguetes del poder.
Pensadlo un momento, ¿qué hacía el estado
perdiendo el tiempo gestionando hoteles, aerolíneas
o telecomunicaciones?
Gracias a la competencia, el mercado lo puede
hacer mucho mejor, con menos costes y más
innovación.
-> Segundo, muy interesante.
En 35 agencias públicas, que continuaron
siendo públicas, como por ejemplo el sistema
de control del tráfico aéreo, se profesionalizó
la gestión y se les exigió que funcionasen
con criterios de mercado.
El resultado fue espectacular:
No solo mejoró el servicio sino que estas
35 agencias públicas pasaron de costarle
1.000 millones de dólares neozelandes al
gobierno, a generar, entre beneficios e impuestos,
más de 1.000 millones.
Dinero que podía destinarse a educación,
sanidad o cultura.
-> Pero ahí no acabó todo, en absoluto.
Como las regulaciones y las leyes eran muy
numerosas y muy complejas el gobierno puso
a las mejores del país a trabajar con una
misión: simplificarlo todo y eliminar todo
aquello que realmente no aportaba nada.
¿El resultado de todo este cambio?
(“Cuando comenzamos este proceso, el Departamento
de Transporte tenía 5.600 empleados, cuando
terminamos tenía 53.
Cuando empezamos con el servicio forestal
tenía 17.000 empleados, cuando terminamos
17”.)
Ojo, el desempleo no creció, se redujo.
Hay una historia muy… como decirlo, descriptiva.
Lo que pasó con los ciervos.
Sí, con los ciervos, no me he equivocado.
Fijaos.
Cuando los británicos llegaron a Nueva Zelanda
en el país no había grandes animales, así
que algunas familias de dinero llevaron ciervos
para poder cazar.
Y ¿qué creéis que pasó?
Pues que se escaparon y se convirtieron en
una plaga que causaba un daño ecológico
muy importante.
Durante 120 años el estado había gastado
mucho dinero en tratar de combatir esta plaga
para preservar el ecosistema local.
Pues bien, un buen día, con tanta reforma
surgió una nueva idea
¿Por qué no dejar que los campesinos pudieran
cazar y criar los ciervos?
Dicho y hecho.
No solo terminaron con la plaga, hoy Nueva
Zelanda es el mayor proveedor mundial de carne
de venado.
Tiene sentido ¿verdad?
También es interesante lo que paso con los
impuestos, que se simplificaron y se redujeron…
Para sorpresa de algunos la recaudación subió
un 20%.
Los subsidios, por su parte, se cortaron,
no solo en la agricultura también en la industria.
Pero ojo, no os penseis que las reformas fueron
sólo económicas, para nada.
Afectaron también a los servicios públicos.
Mirad lo que pasó, por ejemplo, con la educación.
Durante años el presupuesto no había parado
de crecer, pero los resultados eran peores
¿Acaso es que los estudiantes kiwis se había
vuelto torpes?
No, nada de eso.
Cuando el gobierno investigó las causas se
dio cuenta de que una parte muy importante
del gasto en educación iba a parar no a la
enseñanza sino a cosas administrativas:
agencias de evaluación de la calidad, agencias
de calificación, agencias de expedientes,
etcétera, etcétera.
Y ¿qué creeis que hizo el gobierno?
Sí, se lo cargo todo y le dio el control
de los colegios a un consejo de dirección
elegido por los propios padres.
No solo eso, también permitió que fueran los propios
padres quienes escogieran libremente el colegio,
ojo, público o privado, el gobierno pagaba.
Y ya os adelanto que los resultados educativos
mejoraron… mucho.
Pues bien, así con todo.
Ojo, Insisto, tened una cosa muy clara, Nueva
Zelanda no es el salvaje oeste, para nada.
Nueva Zelanda es hoy un país muy próspero,
con un nivel de vida muy alto y unos servicios
públicos - educación, sanidad, cultura,
etcétera - que están entre los mejores del mundo.
Así que me pregunto...qué mejor ejemplo
para Latinoamérica, o para países europeos
como España, Italia, Grecia o Portugal.
Las cosas se pueden hacer mejor, pero claro....
hay que atreverse a dejar a un lado las pasiones,
y ver qué cosas funcionan y cuáles no.
En fin, si algo está claro, es que la tierra de los kiwis es un gran país.
Pero ahora.. turno para ti, ¿Crees que Nueva Zelanda puede ser un buen modelo a seguir?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y suscribete al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.